so now with your kind permission we'd
like to just tell one brief story a
great cinematographer once said that
anyone can photograph the Grand Canyon
it is difficult to quote
I meant it straight man I really did
what is difficult is to photograph a man
and a woman such is not the case with
our next presenters as they each combine
both beauty and talent in the best
tradition hey Batman couldn't save me
now
and miss Raquel Welch
good evening thank you it's our great
pleasure now to announce for the best
achievement in cinematography the
nominations are John Alonso for
Chinatown Phillip Landrum for
earthquakes
Bruce Surtees for Lenny Jeffrey Unsworth
for Murder on the Orient Express Fred
Cana camp and Joseph byrock for the
towering inferno and the winner is the
winners are Fred Cana camp and Joe Varro
for the towering inferno
you better take both holes one for Joe
thank you Wow
Joe couldn't be here tonight so I'll
accept both of these Berlin you're out
there god bless you for having us on
this wonderful picture
John Gilman the director thank you
both Joe and I want to thank two crews
who really worked terribly hard on a lot
of very difficult effects and another
cameraman that should be up here bill
Abbott who did the special effects we
certainly want to thank him thank you
all very much